I've said before we just can't allow the
American right-wing to hold a monopoly
on so-called patriotism because as I've
pointed out many many times the right
uses patriotism as a tool it uses
military veterans as a prop
it uses law-enforcement as a political
posturing tool and Donald Trump
specifically has also used 9/11 to try
to prop himself up in truly vile and
disgusting ways and once again he seems
unable to help himself he gave a brief
statement yesterday announcing that the
9/11 victim compensation fund has been
signed which is good he could not help
himself from saying I was down there to
talking about Ground Zero and 9/11 take
a look at this few moments I will sign
the 9/11 Victims Compensation Fund this
law makes permanent the financial
support for families who lost precious
loved ones as a result of September 11th
attacks it also provides pensions for
those who are suffering from cancer and
other illnesses stemming from the toxic
debris they were exposed to in the
aftermath of the attacks many of those
affected were firefighters police
officers and other first responders and
I was down there also but I'm not
considering myself a first responder but
I was down there spent a lot of time
down there with you Trump has lied so
much about 9/11 and his role and being
down there and his company's role
here's Trump saying that he helped clear
rubble
[Music]
people were amazing clearing the rubble
trying to find additional lives you
didn't know what was going to come down
on all of us and they I was down there
helping a little and you didn't know
what was going to come down on us I
guess he's saying which is a total lie
and this is not just a liar but this is
a disgusting liar this is the closest
you can get to sort of stolen valor
which applies specifically to the
military without it actually being
stolen valor
and if you want Donald Trump's real
genuine reaction to 9/11 it's on video
look no further than at what Trump said
when he called into some television
station after 9/11
thanks to 9/11 resulting in the
destruction of the Twin Towers Donald
Trump realized that his building in
lower Manhattan was apparently the
tallest one left standing in that
neighborhood a really stupid
accomplishment but that's where Donald
Trump's mind went and if you don't
believe me we have the clip take a look
at this you have one of the landmark
buildings down in the financial district
40 Wall Street did you have any damage
or did you know what's happened down
there well it was an amazing phone call
I made 40 Wall Street actually was the
second tallest building in downtown
Manhattan and it was actually before the
World Trade Center was the tallest and
then when they built the World Trade
Center became known as the second
tallest and now it's the tallest this is
a despicable person I mean truly this is
someone who is completely amoral I was
down there too he says to 9/11 victims
first responders their families who
actually did suffer on 9/11 and who
can't even afford health care now which
is why we need to even pass this bill to
begin with and then just remember the
long track record that Donald Trump has
he promised to donate $10,000 to the
9/11 victims which for a guy as rich as
him is nothing and then he never
actually donated it but he kept taking
credit for it publicly Trump has claimed
that he had employees that he sent down
to work at Ground Zero there's no
evidence of that whatsoever at all Trump
said he watched people jumping out of
the windows of the World Trade Center on
9/11 by looking out of his window that's
not true just that there's no evidence
of that Trump claimed
he lost hundreds of friends in 9/11 has
not been able to name a single one and
then of course his lies extend beyond
just his sort of personal delusions of
grandeur he also has said that he saw a
thousand Muslims celebrating in New
Jersey or something which is of course
untrue widely debunked
and he's been called out about that in
the past there are lies and there are
lies and these are lies that are
particularly gross and disgusting lie
about the size of your crowd as he often
has okay this is another level
altogether it's truly beyond the pale
and what fundamentally is at the core of
this is that nothing can be about just
other people if Donald Trump is giving
someone an award it partially has to be
about how he had the great sense to give
them the award how he is going to take
heat from someone because he has chosen
to give this award I mean there is
nothing that Donald Trump is unable to
make about himself and this is yet
another one of those examples if you
love learning new things you probably
want to check this out the David Pakman
show today is sponsored by Skillshare
and we're giving you two entire months
of free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job
gotten a ton out of it Pat has taken
some courses that he's found really
valuable and I think you'll love it to
get started for free by clicking the
link under this video